hi everybody I'm Katya and I'm here with
the sister I never wanted the mother I
never had and the business partner I
probably should tolerate Trixie the
towel hi hello you should ask me some
questions how are you feeling today
well I'm what about this lighting
beautiful so for the people at home
dying to know the realty as it were
just who is Trixie matome Trixie Mattel
is I've realized early on that a certain
concoction of cosmetics hair product and
mixing of music mm-hmm makes people very
interested in buying me drinks oh okay
so at 21 when I was poor I could either
go to the bar out of drag and let me out
of drag I'm a Cabbage Patch Kid pulled
up to the bar being like somebody want
to talk to me yeah answers always know
yeah or I could go in there like this
I'd be like can't anybody buy a girl a
drink and they're just so excited
they're chucking bottles of Cheetos that
really go if I die this is my legacy
once you start getting paid to do it
you're like why yeah yeah if you're
going to suck the fun out of everything
I do that naturally yeah yeah be poor
and happy don't be rich and mad no what
is something nobody knows about Trixie
Mattel well you see this leg nobody
knows about me I did fail my driver's
test four times four times four times
and I cried almost every time and then
when I finally passed I was like
actually in shock ever gotten somebody
pregnant no I've never been with a girl
okay
um okay you got three kids three boys
what do you name them right now oh
that's a great question I saw August was
most beautifully for really very boy yes
okay
August August three kids we're doing
August okay
Oh honestly I would need my kid a
stripper ho named diamond Oh
like her name is not diamond and this is
Gus Marcus and a stripper who named
diamonds
so you have to say the whole thing every
time
perfect yeah what living person do you
most despise people that have like
stencil on the wall that says love
inspired yeah I don't know whatever the
third word is but yeah like yeah what
turns you on
oh oh created three oh I'm a plain on
the TV there Sudokus and I love to do it
and get like visibly frustrated or
visibly celibate tree okay so I'm like
and I'll get a whole line and be like
it's a pseudocode girl it's a puff
it's a Caucasian thing okay what it is
okay yeah it's people pretend to have
problems that's what it is what turns
you off hey lubbers come on to me which
I haven't a lot and drag really oh my
god you're never in taxi drivers oh my
god what I look like a woman
meet you I was I was in a car on the way
to a podcaster once and this guy was
driving he kept looking at me after I
before I got to the cab he said you're
very beautiful and I was like uh I know
and they he reached behind and ran his
hand down my fish netted Capezio
industrial fish knitted leg oh I bet he
was in for a surprise
I don't think probably wasn't expecting
this lecture yes yeah yeah well his hand
went straight through
he was driving a hologram oh I think
that's I think people and should feel
safe in cars with strangers
yeah gonna get inherently like back in
the day you remember they'd be like
don't you ever get in a car with
stranger and now it's there's an app hey
I would like a stranger to come get me
totally
murder true it's just sort of like a
fancier version of hitchhiking if you
think about it it's hitchhiking meats
tender its tenderness hiking what is
your life's motto
that you are not that great it's like
when people are like I get when I'm at
home a night I'm afraid people are
trying to murder me get a murder you
yeah you think it satisfaction from
offing Cheryl from officemax
joggers if heaven is real what do you
hope God says to you when you get there
and I think you would have to have abs
to get into heaven okay so so look good
no no all right well that's all the time
we have if you guys want to see more of
our hot sexy gorgeous nubile bodies you
can check us out on the wiper Sets Plus
app for our show
[Music]